und wir sind seit leute das ist mir dann
einfach die selbe und herzlich
willkommen tsum leute ihr seht dem titel
22 live also erst mal ich mir leid dass
ich gleich mal handy und ich bin 22
geboren 18 was fällt dir meinen
geburtstag machen außerdem musik laut
sein und was kann jemand geburtstag
machen dachte mir so ähnlich wird sich
mit 22 mache ich einfach 22 fragen in
einem livestream aber durch irgendwelche
fragen sondern so viel hinter der kamera
halo hat fragen herausgesucht die ich
selbst nicht gesehen habt ihr die
gestellt und ich glaube dass ein paar
heftige dabei nicht mehr die haben wir
jetzt live und unzensiert beantworten
und quasi deswegen live weil ich jetzt
keine möglichkeit habe irgendwie zu
chatten oder herauszuschneiden ist
einfach zu meinem geburtstag für euch 22
fragen direkt in die tres ehrlich und
lieber los würdest du einen veränderten
ich würde es nicht ausschließen also
könnte man kann durchaus sagen was ist
das peinlichste dass der prophet ist das
peinlichste was mir passiert ist gut
sollten das jetzt nicht sagen ich glaube
mit das beste was mir passiert ist war
dass ich ok cherie voller geht die
seiten über man etwas machen jungs so
etwas mal 50 jungs wenn die in ihrem
zimmer sind okay wer sich vor und was
passiert damit vielleicht elternteil
dass ich in diesem zimmer hinein begeben
das war auf jeden fall das fenster sehen
was passiert ist ich habe jetzt so
erscheinen also ja bis jetzt blicke ich
weg momentan ein bisschen mehr gas geben
für meine uni ich muss an meine
bachelorarbeit schreiben ich leider als
er macht somit meine bachelorarbeit
leute alle außerdem spielen so ja oder
ja ich habe von 80 seiten geschrieben
ich so alles vielleicht nicht mal von zu
lesen da bin ich mir machen ich bin mir
auf youtube machen
aber ansonsten ist okay
also gebt mir mal was dachtest du mal
demnächst schwulen ja doch aber ich
glaube dass es irgendwann nicht so kann
man doch nicht so fest sagen irgendwie
ne also das ist ändert sich auch immer
man soll ja also ich bin so wie sollte
man ich denke immer menschen können sich
so krassen laufe ihres lebens verändern
wenn ich mir überlege wie ich so vor
fünf jahren drauf habe ich heute glaubt
bin keine ahnung nicht wo ich jetzt in
fünf oder in zehn
ich habe keinen plan überhaupt keine
ahnung welchen youtuber fest in welchen
ich bin ich auf jeden fall feiert er
sofort von moroso noch krasser aber
lappen vor respektabler typ
unsympathisch den feiere ich weniger
lustig gab mir überlegen
ich will es nicht immer ein problem so
viele lehrer maschine oder abgrenzende
auto stand die antwort lässt schwierig
jedenfalls weniger
[Musik]
aber ich glaubte unternehmer unter der
hand voll auf jeden fall unter laden
feuer aber so gar nicht so mehr kraski
aber okay was würdest du dir wünschen
wenn du ein sonst feiert ist was sich
wünschen wenn ich einen wunsch frei ich
glaube ich will mir vielleicht größten
testung sorgenfreiheit in den wünschen
dass man halt komplett ohne sorgen so
läge glaubt ja hast du ein wichtiges
datum wenn ja warum also natürlich ein
geburtsdatum was ja als vielleicht auch
ein paar tagen war ich 22 geworden wenn
das natürlich kasse aber ansonsten
im jahr eigentlich nicht so viel
eigentümer geburtstag hast du schon mit
drogen zu tun
nein eigentlich überhaupt nicht einlösen
aber ganz normal so wie es bei den
allermeisten jugendlichen ist ein mann
tritt man bier oder man kann aber auch
meinen oder sowas aber darüber hinaus
wir haben nicht viel
auch erfahrung gemacht aber keine guten
und das ist die hälfte davon weg dass
man den schlimmsten erlebten moment
schlimmstes erlebnis auch schwierig zu
sagen kannst du wissen so die privaten
anschauen
ich würde sagen also mit recht schön ist
auf jeden fall so wenn die eigenen
eltern sich so aus dass irgendwann hat
mich auf jeden fall ja es hat ja welche
verliert verliert gegen 13 ich finde
manche zuschauer waffen sind nicht so
ganz
also die können sich nicht nicht so rein
versetzen die lage wie es ist wenn man
jetzt selbst gibt über ist und was man
sich dann selbst denkt die denken sie
dann zum beispiel objekt krass wenn
typen trifft jetzt gerade den heute
schon länger mal sehen vielleicht und
eskalieren dann komplett und ja aber
schenkt nicht so dass die andere seite
das vielleicht für das die andere seite
so zu viel ist also manchmal treibt
damit dass sie nicht so ganz verstehen
wie es für hält der youtuber oder der
der musiker oder der der schlagersänger
fühlt hast du schon mal die tour bzw
eine zeit wird es ja doch schon eher das
hätte auch ein mädchen heiraten wenn von
der stadt wäre wo als verrat
also ich würde auf jeden fall
verhandlungen dafür übernehmen also
richtig abgespeist frage aber ja ich
finde meine kinder die welt setzt jedoch
heißt es hier geschehen muss man dafür
auch verantworten
[Musik]
ich glaube am ende ist familie wichtiger
als die familie hast du schon mal
gedacht besseren leben als mädchen
einfacher werden
nein auf keinen fall schwerer listig
afrika dann macht es einfach wichtig
gewesen weil wir mehr abonnenten haben
ja klar das gibt es schon also ich bin
immer ich weiß nicht wieso ein bisschen
ärgert siegertyp und nicht so sehr das
was andere vielleicht so erreicht haben
oder wieso sind und dann denke schon
okay ist jetzt auf die an klar
also ja doch schon also jetzt nicht so
flüssig dessen den spot alter scheiße
weil das auch und jetzt richtig fertig
aber schon was weg können wir schon
blendend weil man ja meinen typus plan
ist
ich würde nach wird so zum zum merkel
steht vielleicht morgen morgen
vielleicht ein buch lesen juni also
lediglich spaß aber dazu später klar
also ich muss jetzt auch ein praktikum
von meiner uni machen falls also da muss
ich dezember bis januar in london
arbeiten das ultrabook space danach bank
wahrscheinlich nach köln zurück fest
geworden und dann youtuber vollzeit
was hast du schon gekommen
[Gelächter]
oder sagen glaubt bekommen in kuchenform
aller tanze hier aus körle tablett aber
man gedenkt war echt cool weil ich so
ein riesen tamtam und riesenechsen aber
ich habe einfach meine familie hier
gehabt ich habe meine meine freunde hier
gab es pläne was sagen deine freunde
damals
youtube also meine engen freunde als man
folgendes gesagt meine engen freunde
haben eigentlich seid ja ok cool und so
allen weiteren bekannten so also nicht
ihre engsten freunde so lange so weiter
außen rum sind
den habe ich das eigentlich gar nicht
gesagt was ultralange verschiedene
halten so locker zweieinhalb drei jahre
bist wie man so 304.000 abonnenten hat
so oder so dann bist du mal erzählt und
weil ich ganz gut so aber weil also in
meinem umfeld ist bisher gar nicht so
dass sollte seinen super krass der
youtuber wie peinlich weil sie menschen
haben die school findet man irgendwas
macht ich sage ja mit diesem wagen heute
tatsächlich planung und zwar weil die so
mitte november bis anfang dezember was
wird wieder match geben
die designs stehen größtenteils schon
der partner über den ist gemacht werden
wird steht also auf unsere nacken wird
kommen sagt traktor offen
[Gelächter]
also ich würde das vielleicht auch ja
ich will ja immer noch eigentlich auch
mal drauf und repariert und so die
allermeisten können nicht auf youtube
deutschland definitiv nicht diesen so ja
ja ich habe einen zug ein vorbild ich
bin ich selbst der krasseste und ich
kann alles am besten und folge dass kein
fall der aber es gibt schon ein paar
leute die finde die idee gut durchziehen
ich bin ich selbst abschaltete sehr gut
wissen lustiger blut und luca zum
beispiel zieht selber durch der iss aus
der präsident hat das auch eine
diffizile sache die auch wichtig ist und
ja ich hatte ich trotzdem
[Musik]
also baby kann man so von der geschäfts
seite ja so von der wirtschaftlichen
seite ja also wie ich gemacht hat wie
sie sich reingehängt was sie für sich
aufgebaut hat kann man das sehr
respektieren denn gehst so von der
persönlichen seite bin ich einfach nicht
so die zielgruppe und findet auch so die
lieber kommerzialisierung also dieses
über krasse auf maximal gehen nicht so
cool
ihr kennt ja vielleicht paraphiert das
video beruhigt auf das video mit vier
places reagiert habe das ist für mich
aber ich bin so so von der
geschäftszeiten gemacht von der aso
persönlichen seite da ist es auf den
könnte mein ding aber keine ahnung ich
persönlich auch die marken ist so weil
ich mag so die bw die sowie geschäfts-
wie mag ich aber die youtube gewinnen
und dann haben wir 220 willst du scheiße
das heckenschneiden kann jetzt kann man
aber so einen button der interwetten die
leute das waren 22 222 geburtstag
schreiben sie kommentare heute ist
gespannt alles klar dann würde ich dann
fühlst du schon leute und bleibt fresh
und werdet auf 22 das ist eigentlich ans
licht
[Musik]